-♪ Chilled wine, roast chicken ♪
♪ Sitting on the island
in a beautiful kitchen ♪
-♪ Big windows, strong women ♪
♪ Scarf's Cashmere
and the pants are linen ♪
-♪ Clawfoot bathtub
filled with bubbles ♪
♪ Handsome neighbors,
someone's got a slip cover ♪
-♪ And Diane Keaton
finding love again ♪
♪ When I need a little heart
and I want to be inspired ♪
♪ I get cozy on the couch,
watch a film by Nancy Meyers ♪
-♪ Where Meryl Streep
owns a bakery ♪
-♪ Meryl Streep bakes
croissants ♪
-♪ When something's gotta give,
take a holiday from life ♪
♪ To the Hamptons, Santa Barbara
or the English countryside ♪
♪ With the nicest rugs
I've ever seen ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-♪ Huge candles, wool socks ♪
♪ Giant bowl of lemons
and jar full of rocks ♪
-♪ White bathrobe, Jack Black ♪
-♪ All the pots are copper
on the hanging pot rack ♪
♪ King size doobie meant
for sprawling ♪
♪ Sparking up
with Alec Baldwin ♪
-♪ And a visit
from Mr. Napkinhead ♪
♪ When I need a little heart
and I want to be inspired ♪
♪ I get cozy on the couch,
watch a film by Nancy Meyers ♪
♪ Where Robert De Niro
does Tai Chi ♪
-♪ Tai Chi in the park ♪
-♪ When you're trying
to plan a wedding ♪
♪ While you're
doing renovations ♪
♪ Do a house swap for a lie ♪
♪ That isn't quite
as complicated ♪
-♪ With butcher blocks
and farmhouse sinks ♪
-♪ I want to meet my secret twin
at summer camp in the evening ♪
-♪ We'll eat Oreos dipped
in peanut butter ♪
-♪ 'Cause our taste
are just the same ♪
-♪ I need a little heart,
I want to be inspired ♪
♪ I get cozy on my couch,
watch a film by Nancy Meyers ♪
♪ Where Cameron Diaz
learns to live ♪
♪ So does her date
with Jude Law ♪
-♪ In a film with Nancy Meyers,
life is how it ought to be ♪
♪ Celebrating every special
moment with your crazy family ♪
♪ So this one's for you, Nancy ♪
♪ Nancy ♪